So, to quickly summarize, I discussed
a variety of issues of dynamic range,
what it is, and relate it back to also
things like how we can see some details
of dynamic range, and how we can capture
that kind of information in real scene.
We basically talked about how image
acquisition pipeline is aimed at
capturing the scene radiance and we
want to use that to convert to pixels.
We basically talked about
a variety of linear and
non-linear aspects of the image
acquisition pipeline.
Again, remembering that really what we
want to do is capture the scene radiance
of a real scene, and
convert it to the pixel values.
And how the whole pipeline works and
how we can represent and model this.
Then we basically talked about the whole
idea of camera calibration, which was
aimed at basically, using a lot of data,
a data-driven method to be able to
map the information about what scene
radiance was and what pixel values were.
This allowed us to create a profile
that can be used to then of course,
do the opposite.
Given a pixel value, what would be
the best scenery radiance for it.
Then we talked about
basically to do this mapping.
Basically how do we go from pixel
values to different exposure images.
And then a, a new radiance
map that captures a scene.
Then we talked about how tone mapping
could be used to take the radiance map
to then display an image in
the displays that we have available.
There is a lot of work out
there in the HDR area.
I'm just listing a few
of the papers here.
Other papers I will make
available also on the website.
So you should be able to
look at them carefully.
These are the ones I referred to
in this slide, sort of slide deck.
And of course,
there are lots of softwares out there.
I encourage you to look at
things like Exposure Fusion,
that's an additional method.
Builds on a whole lot of stuff
that we talked about and
builds on explorant photography.
And of course these types of HDR images
are now available on your cell phones.